Hello everyone, this is Frank Defratis, and welcome to another week of HoloTalk for the week of April twelfth of nineteen ninety-eight.
Our special guest this week is Steve Province from Blue Ridge Holographics.
If you are a new listener, welcome aboard.
This week Holotalk begins transmission of its broadcast to your computer with the real audio server software, which opens up the show to millions of other listeners who could not access the show before because you need to do real audio software f I believe 4.0 and 5-0.
This opens it up to everyone else uh with the earlier versions as well.
So if you're listening to HoloTalk for the first time, welcome aboard.
Um we're going to get to the Steve Province interview in just a moment.
Uh next week I'm going to have a guest, Todd Stark, who is director of uh exhibits and education at the Discovery Center of Science and Technology.
And he's going to fill us in on the new traveling exhibit that's coming to the center uh here in Alltown Bethlehem and Eastern area from Pacific Science Center called Lasers and Holograms.
So we're going to do a short interview with him next week.
That'll go up on Sunday night, so don't forget to stop by and listen to that.
Okay.
I'm not going to come back on after the Steve Province interview is completed.
It's a interview that runs about 25 minutes.
So what I'll do right now is just thank you for tuning in and looking forward to having you come back as a listener week after week.
So this is Frank Defratis from HoloTalk, and here's the Steve Province interview.
Hello.
Hi, Frank.
Steve.
How are you doing?
I'm doing quite all right.
So let's let's start out.
You know, there's a question I've had for you and I want to ask you.
You know, this show's been on uh since November, and I think you're probably the first person that's actually a professional holographer that has a company that's manufacturing holograms I've had on here.
Here's a question for you.
There's a lot of kids that listen to this show.
They listen to it in their schools or listen to it in their home computers.
Now, if you could give them some tips, would you advise them to someday get involved with the field of holography or wouldn't you do that?
Um it depends on what kind of animal you've got.
Mm-hmm.
Um holography's attracted a lot of flakes over the year.
Um there's just something about bright lights.
You know there's there's been an awful lot of flaky people but i what what it takes to have fun in holography is just creative desire.
That that most people who ever saw holograms uh knew at the first instant they ever saw a hologram that they wanted to do it.
Mm-hmm and and it wasn't just a cure a a mild curiosity, it was uh you know quite an inspirational event, a small epiphany, you know when they first saw a good hologram.
And that drives those who will be driven, you know, to uh learn how to do it.
But there's three different ways anybody in Emmy any imaging field goes about making a a living out of being a a creator in any medium is you kinda end up being part artist, part scientist and part businessman.
And that's where a lot of the longevity uh among various players in the field is kind of falling apart.
There's some very talented artists in the field, but they don't have a lick of business sense.
Mm-hmm.
And there's some excellent scientists who are unable to convey any emotion into the technical exercise of creating a hologram.
Yes.
And there are a lot of businessmen who may have, you know, pure greed profit ground floor of a new industry in mind who don't have a sufficient appreciation for the science end or the art end.
And those three worlds of art, science and business have have often been in collision in the field of holography.
It's really it's a communication media.
Yes.
It ain't it ain't no special animal.
I'm in Virginia, I can say ain't.
Um it's it's uh really a a way of of informing people we happen to be more in the commercial end.
Mm-hmm.
So we're typically trying to inform people about uh to be candid, you know, of uh a company's vanity you know that they have arrived as they're uh with it.
And how to show that through holography.
Yes, they they'll use holography because it is is new and exciting as a vehicle to promote uh their view of themselves.
Mm that they themselves are innovative and and look at things different ways.
And uh so it's a good reflection on companies who use it.
Um but it is it's a communication tool uh as far as it's being used for us and also with the good artists.
I've had a few people on the show that were involved with the education ed and they said that they wouldn't recommend kids look into it as a job choice.
And you know I I know there's not much of an industry out there but you know these kids are in eighth grade and they love holography.
They love lasers, they collect holograms and someday they'd like to grow up and go out into the field.
Uh develop some hard skills as far as how to run the equipment and produce the holograms and bring some soft skills along with it, you know, as far as creative thinking and the thought process and I I just can't see sometimes you know shutting them off like that to tell them no one's a good choice.
There's not a need to shut them off but you know there's levels of passion.
Yeah um that that relate to anything and holography's a really good comparison.
You know and and anybody listening has probably met people who are uh audiophiles you know into the very high end ultimate sound systems for which they can invest you know tens of thousands of dollars to chase down that final of noise free high fidelity.
Yes.
Whereas you can go down to Walmart and for ninety nine bucks, you know, pick yourself up a sound system that will allow you to have a rudimentary appreciation of uh of music.
Mm-hmm.
And so it it it does it become a a level of passion.
But one neat thing about holography, although you know, uh the the entry ante because there are few studios, I mean y you've got a you've got a learning studio.
Uh there's some out in San Francisco uh that teach courses, uh Jeff Murray's group.
Um uh Jason Sapan in New York City, I believe still teaches.
Uh but you know, the number of of hands-on educators uh to a person wanting to take a course uh is is kind of limited.
Yes it is.
And in the university environment, it's generally taught just as a peripheral segment to, you know, other studies, typically in the physics department.
Mm-hmm.
Um and you're not gonna run into a lot of physics professors who are gonna pick up pom poms and steer people towards a career in holography.
Uh they find it to be an interesting teaching vehicle.
But you know, you can play um i in the game for you know, somewhere around fifteen hundred to two thousand dollars.
You know, s to build the the the basic uh, you know, uh old Jerry Pethick Lloyd Cross, you know, initiation system.
Mm-hmm.
You know, the sandbox, uh the least expensive grade Edmund lenses.
And and get a rudimentary understanding.
But you stand in front of uh uh a very impressive Margaret Binion piece and look at your dark green two by two inch reflection hologram, you know, you're you're gonna get a complex.
Mm-hmm.
Uh uh there's a much higher stakes uh of anti.
Unfortunately around the world the universities harbor uh the type of equipment you know that that can be available to students, high end equipment.
Yeah.
And in the private sector it's it's a lot more limited.
You know, it it used to be a lot more open in this field, uh, from a informative educational point of view, uh as well as an open door policy for people who were anxious to learn and become involved.
Uh before anybody made a buck.
Yeah.
Uh the dollar reared its ugly head and all of a sudden all this real free flowing information somehow closed up.
Uh sometime about the early eighties um that you know uh when the dollar uh appeared into the scene, uh people got a lot more tight mouthed where they used to uh you know, things became proprietary.
They used to be considered discovery.
And uh that that cast a different a different light.
Did you think we would be further along in holography than what we are today and and why aren't we where we thought we would be today.
Do you have any feelings on that?
It's primarily greed.
Greed.
Yeah.
Uh like I say when when when money started to appear uh patents uh became weapons mm-hmm instead of a mere acknowledgement of of of who thought this up first right uh they became weapons to try to beat away and stifle uh innovation and competition uh because there were dollars at stake, you know, and as soon as uh the Visa Card came around uh that pretty much set the whole game off.
There was big money at stake in protecting uh the patents.
Do you do mostly embossed holography there?
Uh we do not emboss, we do origination for embossed holograms, photoresist masters.
Mm-hmm.
Tell us a little bit about Blue Ridge while we have everyone's attention and I wanted to let everyone know that there's a link to Blue Ridge holographics website that will be on the Holo Talk page and you just click on that link.
You don't have to sit there and stare at your screen while you're uh listening to the show 'cause the real audio player will play in the background while you visit their website.
So why don't you go now and click on that link and Steve's gonna tell us a little bit about what you're gonna find there and what they do.
Well uh we didn't design our own website but I think it came out pretty okay dokie.
Mm-hmm.
Um effectively Blue Ridge uh is sort of a multiple entendre.
Um originally the company since eighty three had been Steve Province holography.
Mm-hmm.
And uh we started in the Santa Cruz Mountains, uh old Doobie Brothers country um uh up above Santa Cruz and uh the earthquake started driving us kind of crazy.
Mm.
And uh also w I had uh a longtime associate Nelson Poe, uh, who who's still with me, who uh well the earthquakes were killing us.
Wow.
And not out of fear of dying but when you wake up and see a a seventy thousand dollar laser teetering on the edge of a table uh ready to cr ready to would have crashed with one more trimmer, you realize how fragile your livelihood is.
Uh I watched a seventeen hundred pound Newport table literally dance across the laboratory floor.
Wow.
Um during the Loma Prieta quake.
Was that your lab that got heart hit out there?
Uh I read about it.
I think it might have been a holography news or something.
They said in one of the labs just labs were just completely destroyed.
I think Light Impression uh took it on the chin, uh, with with a bunch of stuff falling over.
Uh we've been pretty fortunate.
Uh uh it was just minor stuff.
Some some clean benches crashed and HEPA filters got poked through and stuff like that.
But uh it wasn't those events that actually spooked us from uh, you know, working in Quake Country, it was the bloody aftershocks.
'Cause a lot of the shots we do record uh, you know, seven or eight different elements or channels, all done in a sequence.
You know, tightly registered sequence.
And all of a sudden, one out of seven for no explainable reason, the shot wouldn't come out.
Now, photoresist as as you may know is is a very slow uh very insensitive animal.
So it pushes exposure times up into the minutes range instead of the seconds range.
And frankly, after you'd spent, you know, six hours getting through a sequence of thirteen individual recordings on a single plate, only to find that one of them dropped out because some little tremor you couldn't even feel had mucked it up, you'd have to start all over.
And after having to do every job two or three times to get lucky enough to avoid a miss, uh, we just sort of said, you know, this is counterproductive.
So we loaded up the truck and we moved from Beverly and uh came over to the Blue Ridge Mountains.
Wow.
Uh, which is gorgeous here in Charlottesville, Virginia.
It's stable.
These are the oldest mountains in the whole country.
Yeah.
They ain't going nowhere.
And uh frankly, the the costs of electricity of which we consume quite a bit, and the availability of water of which we consume quite a bit, uh, and also prices for real estate, uh, were were much more favorable than they were in California.
So we're we're Blue Ridge because we're right here in the bosom of the Blue Ridge Mountains.
What the fuck is Blue Ridge because we work with Blue Light and we make ridges and grooves.
Oh cool.
That's cool.
What what kind of jobs you take on from people if someone was listening to the show and they were thinking in the back of their mind, you know, I'd like to have a couple holograms done or something.
What what type of jobs do you do for clients?
Well, uh embossed is primarily a mass production medium.
So it doesn't really work out for people who say, hey, it'd be great to have a custom embossed hologram on a couple hundred of my business cards.
Mm-hmm.
Um the person who picked up that ball and ran with it is uh Peter Shire, eighty two thousand.
Uh who you can also you can link to off of my site.
Mm-hmm.
He's gonna be a guest coming up, I think in maybe four weeks, I think, one low run productions.
Yeah.
Pete Peter filled an interesting niche, um that that he can accommodate people who need fewer than a couple thousand pieces of something.
Mm-hmm.
And we've done jobs uh where I mean uh to be candid, the mastering nut, you know, runs around four or five thousand dollars to get these things done.
Then in order to get a nickel die, you know, to print the things, you're looking at another five hundred thousand dollars or so.
Mm-hmm.
And by the time you've got somewhere in the neighborhood of, you know, five to seven thousand dollars ante involved, you're gonna want to print a few of 'em.
Yeah, for sure.
Because 'cause once you've got that tooling out of the way, you're dealing with very inexpensive printing.
Uh but for small quantities it doesn't work.
We we've done a few vanity things for uh some companies who had some, you know, big managers meeting and they really wanted to impress the socks off 'em and would do it for enough brochures to cover a few hundred people coming to a meeting.
But uh that sort of that level of corporate vanity is few and far between.
Mm-hmm.
Typically they're used for annual reports, uh things that are in the neighborhood of thirty, forty, fifty thousand units and up and uh more and more and more.
Uh small security labels, you know, they're everywhere.
The dog bones on she's and uh foreign uh you know things like bus passes and and just little authenticity items.
But we're primarily a custom house.
We we are not any longer in the the stock image sales business.
So we're typically dealing with with agencies and we have a very effective uh broker network and we're on very good terms with the great majority of foil embossers uh around the world.
Um and that's primarily where our things come from.
Most people start with their printer and the printer doesn't know exactly where to go so they go to their foil supplier.
Mm-hmm and their foil supplier leads them to a designer or directly to us.
And that's where the majority of uh uh work comes from and we we stay quite busy during certain seasons and uh it's not just a seasonal animal.
Uh you never know what's gonna go on.
Sometimes when the economy's ripping people don't feel they need to advertise as much because it's going great without it.
Sometimes when there's a recession people feel they need to advertise even more.
Sure.
Yeah.
Uh but uh it it it's a very interesting i I I can't you back to one of your original questions.
Would you recommend someone get into holography?
Um not just holography but any independent business is like a yo yo and you've got to have a pretty hard stomach for it.
Oh yeah.
It's a roller coaster ride.
It's it certainly is it's feast and famine.
It is and some people just ain't got th the mental stamina uh certainly when you're in what's trying to be stable relationships you know wife and kids and stuff it's kinda hard to make people understand, you know uh the the ups and downs and and lack of regularity uh, you know, present in holography, which is I think is especially a volatile field.
What's your take on the state of holography right now?
I know in your email you said you had a few comments you'd like to make on holography in general, so the floor yours.
Well that see I guess I guess a couple of the things are uh I think I'd already gone over the greed factor.
That's that's the one part that bothers me.
Mm-hmm.
Um but it's just the nature of business.
There sure have been a lot of lawsuits out there um and you know those are rather disheartening but again that's just an indication that somebody has something worth protecting.
Yeah.
Uh it's the nature of that beast.
I I hate to see a lot of holographic talent uh turn themselves into attorneys.
You know?
Yeah.
Um all of a sudden when you know, when people are talking about discovery and they're not talking about a a new image they've got in mind.
They're talking about litigation phase of a criminal trial that they're involved in.
Um that makes sense.
That speaks volumes in itself.
Yeah.
Um I'll throw out one thing.
I I uh I have pretty strong opinions about a lot of players in the field and and I said, Look, there there's there's frequently been enough bad blood among people uh players in the industry.
But I did want to point out, you know, in case somebody says, gee, Province doesn't really seem to respect anybody that there are two people pretty much only, in my opinion, who deserve any admiration or respect um in this industry.
Take a g take a guess.
Who would who would I pick?
Coming from a an embossing uh recording guy's point of view, um who would you think I would have the most respect for?
The the first name that comes to mind with me would be McGrew.
No.
Um I I think I was just referring to him in the uh people becoming attorneys.
Oh, okay.
Creators.
No, I'll I'll he's the name I've always I I've always heard the story when he was down in Norrstown.
Right.
You know, when he we f before he even went out to the West Coast and the whole thing that they were doing down there with uh what the heck was the name of the company that the Goldbergs had down there and Scott and MCA was involved with that company.
This was back in the early days.
Colex.
Holex, exactly.
Yeah.
So h his was the name that I always associated with it right from the very beginning 'cause I'm just north of Norristown.
Right.
So that's that's why that name came.
Well a lot a lot of people that the you know, some of the first ones you run into uh uh are not always the the ones you stick with.
Yeah no I I'd have to say rather than than the guessing game.
The the the two people I most admire in this field are Ken Haynes.
Mm-hmm uh formerly of American bank note and uh I'm not sure of currently but w with Simeon uh that he's always been uh brilliant innovator uh who sort of led the pack uh in new methods of doing things uh with holograms especially relating to mass production and uh Michael Foster who I probably would be remiss in not putting down as you know a genius.
Uh he was the first person to ever make an embossed hologram.
Really?
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Yeah back the old museum of holography back in uh New York.
Mm-hmm uh back when they were on uh twentieth Street uh had a uh little sample case or or or gift case things to sell.
Mm-hmm.
And they had embossed holograms of things like the scuba diver and uh a really neat multi channel Superman comic uh that Mike Foster had made I think as early as seventy two.
I saw that Superman piece.
I think they had that in one of the display cases.
They had that that there permanently for a while.
Uh huh well they used to sell 'em they'd sell 'em for about ten bucks.
And they they were hand pulled, you know.
Yeah, where did Foster where did you do that man?
Did he have his own facility in New York or something?
No, no.
Foster was uh uh I think at the time he was teamed up with uh Rich Rollison.
Oh okay.
Uh out in Utah and and then uh later in Los Angeles.
Uh but Foster's soft embossing methods are uh are r radically advanced uh compared to most other embossing methods.
Um I wish we could do more business with 'em, yeah, 'cause they really uh really, really look good.
Mm-hmm.
And uh he's a chemist.
That's primarily his background.
I see.
Uh but it you know darn good holographer too.
But those are the those are really the two people I'd put at the top.
There's been a whole lot of people that I don't know, I guess I could fault there there's always been because of the equipment expense and the risk of high end holography, uh there's been a lot of people who've who've only made uh a go of holography with what I call a sugar daddy mentality.
Mm-hmm.
I can't do it on my own.
I won't start small.
I need a partner.
Uh I need somebody else's money in order to afford this.
And I'll bring him in as a partner and we'll we'll make a business of it.
And there's been a lot of a long a lot of wrong marriages along the line.
When somebody had the money and somebody else had the desire and skill it's been sort of unfortunate.
There's there's a few self made people.
Um uh it's easy to be jealous of the educators uh because of all the equipment at their disposal.
Mm-hmm.
Um but they didn't buy it.
Yeah, it's all grant.
They didn't buy it, yeah, it's all grant and uh I don't know, we've we sort of prided ourselves in being bootstrap kind of guy.
Yeah.
Are you still there?
Oh yeah.
Oh right.
I w I went through it the same way, you know, with my studio.
I mean I I'm over at Lehigh University now.
We just opened the science museum.
I had, you know, a couple hundred kids this weekend for holography already.
It's already two way.
You know, you're one of the hardest working guys in show business.
Well uh I mean y you cover a lot of bases and there's there's been a lot of gaps created over the years between uh uh gallery closures, the museum itself.
Yeah.
Um the the number of of schools that do carry courses uh following through with you know education br you know broadening people's information base uh and now you're taking it into the web.
I I'm I have to compliment your enterprise.
Well thank you very much.
There there's been a lot of kids that have moved on.
Uh my daughter who just started college this year, my oldest daughter's um a physics major and her physics professor is a student that I had in the early eighties that started out with um learning about lasers and came into the studio and made some holograms.
She's married with her own kids now and she's still got the holograms on the wall.
But it's gone generation to generation now and uh that's you know and the whole reason for this show is basically just to fill a void of information.
You know, just give people an opportunity like yourself a chance you know to come on here and and say what it is you're doing.
You know, in an informal way where people can log on and listen to what's happening with holography 'cause it's so hard to get any information about what's happening.
That's true.
Well I'll give you a basic life truth.
Applies to everything other than holography too.
You only learn stuff solidly by making mistakes.
Mm-hmm.
And the one the brevity of a holography course is unfortunate because there's so much information to absorb that there could be a tendency to be spoon fed and take what the teacher has to say as an absolute law.
Yeah.
Do it this way.
Whereas some of the most innovative work in holography ever done basically resulted from learning something from the freedom to make a mistake.
Yeah.
It and it's it's ta changed the course of imaging uh so many times.
Rudy Burkout uh you think he just envisioned the way some of his things came out I think there was a whole series of happy accidents and boxes of ruined plates before Rudy got the look he got.
Yeah.
And we've everything we've figured out about this game we've basically figured out by trial and error and making a lot of mistakes.
Now I'll throw one other tip out for any any uh student or amateur uh which is don't take everything your teacher says as an absolute um I would recommend to all novices to throw away the beam splitter.
Every explanation of holography I've ever heard says take your laser, split the bean into two parts with a beam splitter.
Yeah.
And I think you've created a fundamental problem right out of the gate.
Low-powered lasers, you've just wasted a lot of light.
Yeah.
And actually if people could practice, and I think they'd find great results in stability, conservation of the amount of light they had, and decreased dispos exposure times by using uh a shear beam technique where you remember that spread out expanded beam through an objective is as many parts as you want it to be.
Mm-hmm.
You just have to take a mirror and s make let one part of it be reference, grab another mirror and let it illuminate a subject.
But take that little piece of glass that's a beam splitter and put it in a drawer for a while.
You know?
Yeah.
All right, well Steve I want to thank you for being a guest taking the time out you know for the listeners that log on for the show.
I appreciate it very much.
Uh we're gonna cut it off now because we try to keep the file sizes as small as possible.
This will probably wind up being close to two megs is the file size.
You're gonna have to edit the heck out of this.
No, no editing.
We'll go up a little bit every word you said is worth a million bucks so we keep every word in.
Alright well before everybody starts yawning we'll have to say goodnight.
All right, Steve.
Thank you very much for being on the show.
Thanks, Ryan.
And look forward to talking to you again.
Okay.
All right, take care.
Bye for you.